اعقب صلاه عيد الفطر اعرب مصلون في جنوب
الخرطوم عن امالهم في انهاء الاقتتال في
البلاد وحقن دماء كل السوداني
العيد ينبغي ان يعيشه الناس بفرح بسرور
ببهجه كبارا وصغارا ولكن للاسف الشديد
يعني نبي الاصوات والرعبه الذي يعني شاع
في النفوس والقلوب فهو جعل الناس لا
يتمتعون بفرحه العيد الحقيقيه التي ينبغي
ينبغي ان يعيشونها والمراه احنا في
الخرطوم يعني بنعيد عيد ممزوج بالحزن
والفرح يعني حقيقه
فقدنا
اعزاء ابرياء لا دخلهم بهذه الحرب يعني
نزال الله ان السودان كل عامة ربنا يحفظه
ويهدي غاداتنا الى طريق الرشد الحمد لله
بحمده وفضله صرنا رمضان نزل لها القبول
وصلينا المسجد في هذا في هذا الصرح والحمد
لله يعني صلينا بامان لكن لاول مره نصلي
داخل المسجد نسبه لاصوات الرصاص به البلاد
نزل الله ان يحقن الدماء